this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace take any circle measure its
circumference and its diameter the ratio
of these two numbers is a mathematical
constant we call pi while this
definition is simple pi has been studied
for thousands of years and history of
our understanding not just of the value
of pi but also what it means forms a
history of all of mathematics it takes
us from the Middle East to Europe to
China to India and even America it's a
history which involves revolutions
murder and the infinite
[Music]
maths is as old as civilization older
even there's evidence of counting going
back thirty thousand years and two of
the very earliest civilizations the
ancient Egyptians and Babylonians both
investigated pi around 4000 years ago
the Babylonians estimated PI to be 3 and
1/8 or 3.125 now that's the first of a
few estimates you're gonna hear in this
video so for reference remember that the
first few digits of pi are 3.1415926
there are more that means that the
Babylonian estimate of Pi is accurate to
1% of its true value which is kind of
astonishing when you remember that this
is a time in human history when iron was
first being used and the last mammoths
went extinct the ancient Egyptians on
the other hand estimated PI slightly
less accurately as 3.16
but how do you even estimate the value
of pi you have to count it by definition
measure a curved surface which is super
tricky to do accurately well one way of
doing it is to cheat and actually use a
square compare a square and a circle
well it's quite a little bit like a
circle but that was much like a circle
as a Pentagon which has one more side
than a square and a Pentagon doesn't
look quite as much like a circle as a
hexagon which has one more side again
and a hexagon doesn't look quite as much
like a circle as a heptagon and so on
you can think of a circle as a regular
polygon just want with an extremely
large number of sides so many sides in
fact that each individual one is
infinitesimally small meaning that the
circle looks round this was exactly the
thinking that legendary ancient Greek
mathematician Archimedes used when
estimating pi around 220 BC in fact it
was probably the very last thing he ever
did to approximate pi he reasoned why
not measure the perimeter of a square
adding up the lengths of all of its
edges and then dividing that number by
the squares diameter but what is the
diameter of a square is it the length of
its diagonal or the length of one of its
edges why not both said Archimedes draw
one square with its corners just
touching the perimeter of a circle
another square with its faces just
touching the perimeter of that same
circle add up the lengths of the sides
of each square divided by their
effective diameters and you have two
estimates for the value of pi the true
value of which lie somewhere between
those two numbers but here's the really
clever part because the difference
between those two values is pretty big
if you're using squares because a square
isn't much like a circle but replace
those squares with Pentagon's and you
shrink the difference between those two
numbers meaning that there's a smaller
range of values that PI could be your
estimation just got more accurate and if
you replace those Pentagon's with
hexagons you'll get an even more
accurate estimates keep increasing the
number of faces on the shape that you're
drawing inside and outside the circle
and your estimate will get more and more
accurate as long as you have the time
and patience to draw said shapes there
is a reason why this thing was called
the method of exhaustion
Archimedes got up to a 96 sided shape
which incidentally is called an a neocon
Turki hexagon I really hope I said that
right giving an estimate of Pi between
three point one four zero eight and
three point one four to nine so accurate
to two decimal places as I mentioned
earlier this was likely his final
contribution to science because into 1/2
BC he was killed by Roman soldiers who
invaded his hometown
Zaira Q's he was apparently performing
this calculation at the time allegedly
his final words were don't disturb my
circles European progress in the study
of pi died with Archimedes for well over
a thousand years fortunately however
there was plenty of the world which was
not in Europe a mathematicians here were
also interested in PI in particular
three mathematical superpowers of the
first millennium ad were China India and
Persia ideas when these three nations
were soon to change the world
first off Chinese mathematicians used a
method of exhaustion similar to our
comedians but instead of considering the
parameters of shapes they considered
their areas and this dude no I'm not
going to try and pronounce his name
because I'll only get it wrong used to
polygon with 3072 sides to obtain pi to
five decimal places 200 years later a
father-and-son team used a polygon with
over 12,000 sides to extend that record
to six decimal places and that was a
world record which stood for 800 years
the problem was it was just difficult to
do these calculations they weren't
especially hard to understand it was
just awkward to write down what you were
doing to physically do the calculation
and this was something that would only
be resolved by the introduction of two
world changing ideas from India and
Persia say that you want to do a
calculation you know that you and your
friends together weigh a hundred and
twenty-five kilos and you also know that
you weigh 70 kilos the question is how
much does your friend weigh
mathematically we'd write this as X plus
70 equals 125 where X is your friends
weight in kilos subtract 17 from both
sides and you get the answer
55 kilos now in that simple example I
just used two ideas which were
revolutionary to the classical world
firstly I wrote large numbers like 125
and 70 using a simple notation we take
it for granted these days but the
ability to write any number using just
ten symbols and a place value notation
where the position of a symbol in a
number determines its size massively
simplifies arithmetic to see what I mean
try and do that calculation only using
Roman numerals our modern decimal
notation was first developed in India
some time before 400 AD and then rapidly
spread to Persia where the second key
idea came from the second key idea was
representing your friend's weight using
some symbol X and then manipulating both
sides of the equation this of course is
algebra originally developed by
Babylonian and ancient
mathematicians but truly established by
Persian mathematician and all-round very
influential dude Mohammed eben Musa
al-khwarizmi using decimal notation and
algebra allowed for much easier
calculations across all of maths and
mathematicians working on calculating PI
used it to turbocharge their work after
the Renaissance and a renewed interest
in mathematics
along with crucially new tools from the
east Europe was back in the game and in
1630 the most accurate estimate of Pi
using the polygon method was achieved by
Austrian astronomer Christiaan grind
Berger who used a shape with 10 to the
40 sides yes really
to calculate pi to 38 decimal places and
then because mathematicians are sensible
people with lives to lead they decided
that was accurate enough and they'd
leave it there oh wait the adoption of
algebra by European mathematicians
triggered a whole new way of looking at
the world a change in thinking generally
grouped under the title the Scientific
Revolution which itself went on to
inspire the Age of Enlightenment with
thinkers like Rene Descartes and John
Locke amongst other ideas the
Enlightenment movement emphasized the
value of Reason over tradition and new
mathematical ideas were held up as
Paragons of this they were pure reason
the change in how 17th century European
mathematicians calculated PI is arguably
a perfect example of the shift from
following what the ancients did to new
rational theoretical approaches because
while the ancients like Archimedes may
have measured the perimeters of shapes
increasingly similar to circles now
European mathematicians were using a
method based entirely on reason a method
based on infinite series an infinite
series is just an expression
made up of things added together one
after the other after the other after
the other and so on until forever if
those contributions keep getting smaller
as you go on then the series converges
to a particular value sometimes you can
work out what that value will be using
logical arguments but sometimes you just
have to keep calculating term after
term after term until you reach an
accuracy that you're happy with the
method of using infinite series to
calculate pi was first used not in
Europe but again in India you could kind
of argue that what Archimedes did was an
infinite series but the first person to
write a mathematical function as an
infinite series was Indian mathematician
math hava of Sangamo grammar in the 14th
century
he wrote down expressions for the sine
cosine and tangent of an angle as well
as the inverse tangent quick refresher
if you write the expression y equals tan
of X the expansion for the tangent would
tell you what y equals if you already
know what X is while the expansion of
the inverse tangent would tell you what
X is if you already know what Y is by
its definition the function tan of X
precisely equals 1 when x equals 1/4 pi
that means that if you have an
expression for the inverse tangent then
if you plug 1 into that expression and
keep calculating terms you'll end up
with an increasingly accurate estimate
of 1/4 pi madhava did this and
calculated PI to 11 digits but then his
method seems to have been forgotten only
to be apparently independently
rediscovered in 17th century Europe by
Scott James Gregory and German Gottfried
Wilhelm lightness and at this point
everything kicked off the new decimal
notation and algebraic technique allowed
for record calculations of Pi in 1699 it
was calculated to 271 digits by abraham
sharp who was beaten in 1706 when John
machen reached a hundred digits who was
in turn beaten by thomas von tete de
l'année
I hope that's how you say his name in
1719 with 112 digits it wasn't just the
case that each of those mathematicians
had more spare time than the previous
one they were competing with each other
using different infinite series which
converged on PI faster instead of just
using the inverse tangent infinite
series they might use a combination of
different inverse tangent values or
something completely different
the competition then became less about
which mathematician had done the most
calculations and instead which
mathematician had the fastest converging
infinite series development of
increasingly efficient infinite series
continued well into the 20th century
with the technique kind of coming full
circle as the current infinite series of
choice was developed by Indian prodigy
mathematician Srinivasa Ramanujan of
course by the 20th century mechanical
computers had been invented making it
much easier to calculate pi you
basically just used one until he got
bored in 1949 Americans D F Ferguson and
John wrench calculated PI to 1120 digits
but they were bringing a knife to a
gunfight
because that very same year the first
calculation of Pi by an electronic
computer was done nearly doubling their
record with two thousand and thirty
seven digits from here the history of Pi
is basically a list of increasingly
powerful computers running for a long
time and spitting out increasingly
absurd numbers of digits at the time of
recording the world record for digits of
pi calculated is held by peter trib with
a shade under twenty two and a half
trillion digits calculated the question
of course is if we know that pi is going
to keep going on forever
it's a transcendental number why should
anybody bother calculating anymore
dishes well for one thing
calculating pi is actually a really good
way of making sure that your brand new
shiny computer is working properly
calculating pi uses up a lot of mental
brainpower for the computer you have an
answer that you can check yours against
and also if you keep going just a little
bit longer than the previous person you
can have a casual world record secondly
pi is actually a really good random
number generator if you look at the
first two hundred billion digits of pi
you'll find the number zero occurs
almost precisely 20 billion times and
the same goes for the other digits 1
through 9 that means that if you were to
pick a random digit in those 200 billion
there's an almost exactly 10 percent
chance of it being one under almost
exactly 10% chance
being to and so on this makes
calculating PI to a large number of
digits very valuable to people that want
to generate random numbers people
working in cryptography for example but
lastly and arguably most importantly
people keep calculating more digits of
pi for the same reason that why people
memorize tens of thousands of digits of
pi and the same reason why people climb
mountains and swim oceans and invent the
double luge because they can humans are
weird
we like to understand the world around
us and as our civilization has developed
we've built increasingly complex tools
to help us understand the world
it wasn't essential for our survival
that we did that we just did it because
of the way we're wired because we could
pie is a thread that's gone through all
of human history because it's a
microcosm of how we interact with the
natural world from the ancients to
present day through revolutions in Thor
and across the world as long as there
are people there's always going to be
somebody who just wanders what's the
next digit long may that continue I'd
like to close out this video with two
quick announcements announcement the
first I finally launched a website go to
the very shiny and new
Simon ox fist calm for a hub for
everything I do online including this
YouTube channel sponge in electric and
the wiki cast there's a page there
detailing the gear that I used to make
these videos and coming soon there's
also going to be a page detailing all
the advice that I give out to people who
are interested in applying to the
universities of Oxford and Cambridge and
then announcement number two if you'd
like a look at my website and why
wouldn't you
I built it with Squarespace who very
kindly sponsored this video before
making this website I didn't have any
experience with web development at all
but it was super easy guys
so easy so quick to use one of their
templates customize it to look the way I
want and then just fill in my stuff and
then bang it's done I never have to
patch or upgrade or install anything
it's all taken care of
brilliant also it was super easy to set
up for selling merchandise which um may
be happening soon you
you'd like to build your own website for
your next project then definitely use
Squarespace for it go to Squarespace
comm for a free trial and when you're
ready to hit the big red button and
build the website go to Squarespace com
forward slash Simon Clark to get 10% off
your first purchase thanks to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
thank you for watching it if you enjoyed
it please do give it a share
pop it alike maybe leave a comment and
thank you again I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]